Peter writing a screenplay does it begin
with the word fade in not in my
experience it begins with the the
excitement of an idea you know Vince
Gilligan said you know when he started
Breaking Bad it was just the idea he was
sitting around with a friend of his and
they were bemoaning the fact that they
weren't working and he just goes man you
know maybe we should cook meth and his
friend laughed ha ha ha and then from
that he had the idea Wow cooking meth
what would that be like so the whole
story came from this little nugget it's
a little excitement and I see that all
the time with writers is whatever
excites you is the place to start in
your story one deadly thing to do is to
go ok well hmm what's selling let me go
to The Hollywood Reporter and see what's
selling right now okay well Horrors not
selling action selling alright I'll
write an action movie that is almost
guaranteed to leave you uninspired I say
right from excitement for a good week or
month and then you'll run out of that
excitement at some point or you won't if
you do run out of excitement then you
can watch or look at tools to help you
or you can just abandon the project but
I've never known a writer who wrote
simply because they had to write
especially starting a project obvious if
you're working on a spec script or if
you're working for money in any way you
sit down on a discipline schedule and
you're right but to start creating a
story that way I've just never seen it
happen excitement is the only key to
telling a great story at the beginning
it's like dating or like a marriage
you'll know really quickly if there's
any chemistry there and if there isn't
any chemistry there it's probably gonna
fail but in any case you you you you
have to write on a schedule I've never
known a writer who didn't write on a
schedule who succeeded who just said I'm
just gonna let inspiration
Karimi where it will I've never seen a
writer succeed doing it that way I'm not
saying you couldn't I've just never seen
it
every writer I know this exceeds has a
discipline about them so included in
that discipline let's say every 10 hours
a writer has per day to dedicate to a
career of those tennant 10 hours should
they be doing various things like
developing an idea writing a screenplay
watching movies which sometimes falls
under the fun part of doing research
which sometimes goes on forever and ever
but if we broke down ten hours a
professional writer should spend on
something every day most writers that I
work with have a amount of pages per day
they want to achieve but I think that's
like asking how you make love I mean you
as long as you get your pages in the day
I think there's one writer I work with
you told me he turn oh buddy in the
world can work at this more than two
hours a day if they say they are they're
lying and but I don't think that's true
I know other writers I've worked with
who literally crank out the chapters on
a discipline basis we just did a book
from an English woman who's a brilliant
writer but she's a financial analyst
she turned her book into the publisher
on time and the publisher was aghast
like we never have that well it's just
she's used to actually having to produce
stuff on a schedule I can't emphasize
enough though that that the discipline
of a professional writer to go ahead and
and and always fulfil the page count for
the day is it sounds mind-numbing it
sounds like working in a factory I'm
just observing those are the writers who
succeed I don't know why that is but
they are the writers who succeed I have
a deadline I must produce I'm producing
it now they all do that why is that I
don't know why do the ones that say you
know I I'm not inspired today
well I'll just watch a movie or I'll do
something fun with research and the
inspiration will come I don't know why
those guys never finished their scripts
I don't know why I'm not judging I'm
just observing who sells scripts and who
doesn't
that's my observation by the way that
was as as a writer that was always my
problem I simply couldn't commit to the
page I'm a wounded writer the reason I
do what I do is I started analyzing
story years ago because I wanted to see
how I could succeed as a writer and then
I got fascinated with story structure
and analysis and tools and how the
seekers all work and then I decided
really come out what I want to do but
I've just never seen a writer who was
undisciplined in the process succeed and
a script writer like Ron bass once told
me he says look I get up at 3:00 in the
morning
and I work I work and work and work I
pace in my garage I work I then I go
back to my desk and I work I think Ron
said you know he works 1214 hours a day
but he always gets his projects in on
time there's a discipline there it's
always you know you just want to observe
who succeeds at it and doesn't and then
you just draw your own conclusions
discipline seems key to me it's
discipline counterintuitive to being a
creative though that's why creators go
crazy that's why they drink is that it's
two opposite things needing to fulfill a
very rigorous discipline structure and
having the personality of a rebellious
miscreant who hates convention and can't
stand following the rules right those
two elements are often necessary for a
creator and it's why creators are all
crazy right because those are opposites
you know I mean rebels
and rule-followers are usually on the
opposite end of a scale so to be able to
combine those two that makes you crazy I
see it all the time I think I think it
really is true that a lot of people in
this business are insane I'm kind of
insane myself I think it I think it's
almost required to have a kind of
schizophrenia to be a successful creator
a commercially successful creator it's
it's not it's not easy and so many of my
students are rebels and so when they
come into this process and I'm start
showing we start showing them tools like
yeah that's going to make my story a
cliche and and the fact is the most
rebellious rule-breaking directors like
Doc Tarantino they they use these tools
the subjects they write they show are
where they rebel they show subjects that
are crazy that you wouldn't ever really
be interested in but the tools they use
are classical or are powerful or
rigorous and they employ them with the
precision of an engineer let's take how
Ashby mmm-hmm wounded gentleman himself
mm-hmm also Hollywood rebel how does he
manage to hunker down somebody that had
a foundation that I think was very rocky
in the beginning but he somehow think he
not sure how he exactly started with
editing something like that he I think
he had an amazing work ethic and it
having an amazing work ethic which is
the same thing that gets you success as
a used-car salesman is exactly a great
valuable tool to have as a creator if
you compare rebellion with a great work
ethic
I see success all the time
and in the creative field it is the
ability to tame your demons and to work
anyway
that seems to be an extraordinarily
important part of success so again I
don't know if you've ever worked on a
set but it's some of the it's 14 16 hour
days there's it's it's kind of like
working in a factory it's there's
there's very little sometimes glamorous
about actually making a story it is hard
friggin work and it's discipline that
propels the people I see actually in the
field they're the hardest-working people
I know one of the writers I work with
actually left Hollywood at 25 he'd had a
career as a TV writer and he went back
to a Midwestern city penniless and he
worked in a used-car lot for four years
and he told me that experience of
becoming a good used car salesman
brought him back to Hollywood any
employed all of those practices you know
sales quotas you know kid out there on
the floor and sell and he now writes big
movies and he's incredibly successful so
and he's also a manic depressive but
he's he's so he's got the discipline and
he's also crazy it's that's a pretty
good recipe for being a successful
writer in Hollywood but I like what you
just said a minute ago you said
something about discipline with your
wounds anyway or something in fact yeah
it's like that's a bumper sticker right
there you you in spite of your trauma
you keep at it you keep at it you work
hard you have a structure you have a
system you're bleeding all over the
place
maybe you wipe the cocaine off your nose
maybe you leave the abusive relationship
that you've just you've been beaten up
over and then you go to the set and you
work or you go to your computer and you
work you you show up and do the work
regardless of what's going on in your
personal life and sometimes your
personal life just takes a backseat but
no matter how chaotic it is the
discipline is always there in the in the
most successful creators I see the
energy they have the energy of ten
people they have
discipline of a guy who's built their
own company the idea that you're this
lazy wildly erratic drug addict who
never gets off the couch and never does
anything that's that's cool but in my
experience those people don't sell their
stories you must develop discipline in
my experience and a great work ethic or
you won't succeed it's it's a myth that
the opium addict who simply sits on
their couch and occasionally write
something and sends it off and gets it
sold I've just never literally seen that
happen not to say it doesn't but I've
never seen it
you